welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn wilshire host and our guest is
David atkin assistant professor of
economics his primary feels our trade
and development professor Atkins
research focuses on evaluating the
impacts of trade liberalization on the
poor in the developing world today we'll
talk with professor atkin about his work
on rug exporting in egypt and
manufacturing soccer balls in pakistan
welcome professor atkin thank you for
having me let's start with the rug
exporting in Egypt tell us about the
project okay so the initial initial
motivation for this project was I guess
there are three actually separate
motivation so firstly there's been a lot
of work in recent years trying to think
of the supply constraints that affect
small firms in developing countries and
prevent them from growing things such as
credit or lack of skills but there's
been very little work which looks at
demand constraints so by demand
constraints I mean if you're in a space
small local market there is not a very
large number of buyers for your product
and that may mean you're not able to
operate it large scale for example so
that's sort of the first motivation to
try and understand if these demand
constraints are really binding for these
are small firms secondly and sort of a
perpendicular to that motivation is
there's a very large literature in
international trade which tries to think
about whether there's a link between a
trade and productivity with many people
are hypothesizing that when you start at
say exporting to foreign countries and
that your productivity may actually rise
because you're learning things through
this process of exporting for example
the buyers but provide you with
information on how to better manufacture
your products and that may actually have
a causal impact on your firm's
productivity unfortunately there's a
second channel which goes in the
opposite direction which is we think
it's the most productive firms who are
the ones who are able to export and this
means it's often hard to tell apart
whether or not actually
the act of exporting changes your
productivity rather than just better and
more productive firms exporting and so
the second motivation is to try and sort
of tease out that causal channel whether
or not actually exporting itself leads
to changes are in productivity and the
third motivation is much more policy
focused which is vast amounts of money
in recent years have been put into
various aid for trade programs where the
idea is that trade can actually be a
method of a alleviating poverty in
developing countries but there's been no
rigorous evaluation of any of these
programs and so the aim was to also
provide such an evaluation okay so what
we're trying to do is we're trying to
understand exactly the impacts that
exporting has on our small producers and
their incomes and their levels of
poverty and so in order to do this we
were looking for a context in the
developing world where we would be able
to generate as some exogenous variation
exporting what i mean by exogenous
variation exporting is we need to
generate a some ability to control which
firms were able to export on which firms
weren't in order for us to actually say
that exporting our leads to changes in
income or changes in productivity and so
we partnered with a NGO in based in
hartford right near to here called aid
to artisans and their methodology was to
go into a small i go work with small
producers in developing countries and
try and bring their products to our
western markets through trade fairs
through how the contacts they have
within the industry and working with
them we highlighted egypt is a
particularly a good location to do this
since they were about to start a large
project there and there are many firms
of the type we were interested in okay
so we went to egypt and we eventually
located a very large cluster of rug
producers in sort of halfway between
Alexandria and Cairo and we've been
working with them
and the essential idea is that the
several hundred produces in that town
and half of them we've given the
opportunity to export their products to
western markets so 350 as there's a
approximately 300 we've been working
with initially and in a second round
we've been working with that another 140
so the way we've been giving these funds
and opportunity are to export is we've
managed to through these trade fairs etc
secure a large number of our orders from
our Western firms and in places like
Germany in the US for example ABC
carpets and home in New York and these
companies have been ordering I various
designs of rugs and we're working with
an intermediary in Egypt and those
opportunities to produce those rugs for
export have been allocated to a subset
of those firms we're working with and
not allocated to the other subset and
we've been choosing which firms get this
opportunity at random and this enables
us to tease out what's the impact of
have being provided with this
opportunity to export mm-hmm so what
have you found I know you're still its
ongoing research but have you made any
what have you found at this point so
we're still at a very reasonable early
stage we're expecting to have our final
results in a few months but so far the
results are very promising a few things
stand out so the first thing that is
most apparent is they've been dramatic
changes in quality in the quality of the
rugs which these are small firms are
producing and why do you think that is
so we've looked into this we can quite a
lot of depth and so we still have a
fairly good handle on exactly what's
going on which is sort of valuable as a
large literature and trade which test
hypotheses that trade changes the
quality levels particularly if you're
exporting to rich or western countries
but we don't know so much about the sort
of nitty gritty details of how that
occurs so in our case we have very very
good a survey data and the technology is
quite easy for us to understand
we can actually see exactly what's going
on so to give you some examples yes when
you sell rugs in the local market the
domestic market Egypt you're a rug
producer and they ask for say a nine by
six rug then you'll make one that say
maybe 8 by 5 and then the next one
you'll make 10 by 6 and you'll say up
it's about right will it's fine let's
just run with that so if you're selling
to a Western retailer of rugs every rug
has to be exactly nine by six a lot of
the purchases particularly are the rugs
going to Germany or interior designers
and they don't want a rug that's
actually 10 by six when they open it up
even though they thought it was nine
basic similarly they didn't want to rug
which when they ordered lime green turns
out to be a different shade of green
right so that's interesting so it's kind
of a cultural thing almost where if
you're producing for your native country
it's okay to have it not be exact but
they know the producers and
manufacturers of the rugs know that is
unacceptable to produce so there's
various reasons why that's not be so
sort of one simple reason was if they're
purchasing in markets in the developing
countries and there's sort of no
repeated interactions and so if this
rugs not quite the right size and you
bring it home I you're not going to not
purchase another rug from that person
because you weren't going to purchase
another one form anyway well the the rug
dealers in the United States if they get
a return on their rug at ABC carbon home
they're not going to keep on ordering
from you when I when the customer
complaints so that could be also what's
going on so that's the the sort of first
thing another thing is if you have a rug
like this rug here it lies very flat so
this isn't a hand woven rug but when you
hand weave rugs it takes a lot of effort
to make sure the rug lies flat it
involves more of a constant level of
care to make sure every notice is
particularly tight and are we've seen
two fairly a dramatic increases in how
flat these rugs lie when they're being
produced for export
and we sort of understand the processes
of how that's occurring there's feedback
coming from the buyer saying these
things are not acceptable and and then
responses from the producers so so
that's sort of one dimension we're
finding these large changes in quality
the other dimension that's particularly
important I think in the Egyptian
context is when we started this project
we weren't able to properly anticipate
the Arab Spring I guess we weren't alone
in that but actually by the time we
started our baseline the events had
already started to unfold and what
that's meant is this is an extremely
volatile time in Egypt and the domestic
demand has been very low a lot of the
domestic demand actually comes from
tourists who are visiting Egypt
purchasing pretty rug with the picture
of the Sphinx on it those guys are no
longer turning up in its large numbers
and so what we're seeing which is a sort
of standard pretty is a standard
prediction of a trade model is if you're
able to export to many countries and
countries sometimes they hit with these
shocks which leads the local demand to
be low then you're going to be protected
through your exports right and so what
we're seeing is we're seeing the
volatility of these guys who are
exporting zinc um is much lower so
they're more able to eat meat on a
month-to-month basis which is a sort of
nice a clean indicator of how wealth
they are given that they're eating meat
approximately once to twice a month and
and those numbers go up easily
dramatically when they get more income
and so essentially what's what we
hypothesize is going on here is your
ability to sell to these other markets
where they don't have as the same
fluctuations in demand means you're able
to smooth out at these events obviously
we're looking at a fairly extreme one of
these events which is the sort of
revolution in Egypt sure which is a very
much disrupted the domestic market and
so while there was also preliminary we
are seeing increase in income reductions
in the volatility of income and also
increases in in quality levels
and as such things are for these small
producers as well so one of one of the
outcomes for you personally must have
been you you learned a lot about making
rugs and the rug business I would
imagine I'd setting that more than I did
into the project yes yes okay and then
do you are there any implications at
this point that you can you know point
too well so I I'm reluctant to commit to
any of this before we have our final
results but it seems if our if the
resulting results are carried through
into the longer run that there is some
benefits of these aid for trade type
programs in alleviating poverty for one
and that's potentially desirable for
example rather than concentrating on say
an intervention which is designed to to
give greater access to credit for small
firms we may think about an intervention
that's designed to improve access to
larger markets for funds maybe not just
access to foreign markets but also
access to the capital city market if
you're in a remote area and these types
of programs may actually be a very
effective and we should sort of
investigate are those types of programs
okay very good now let's go on to the
work you did in Pakistan with soccer
balls let's talk about that project I'm
so this is a timely interview today the
world cup soccer ball was announced Oh
to great fanfare say soccer balls on the
world's mind let me ask you are most of
the world soccer balls made in pakistan
um so historically yes China has been
surging nicely and we think at present
approximately forty percent of the world
soccer balls made in pakistan but what
yeah that was surprising for me to learn
i had no idea so and i would never would
have picked Pakistan Emily so what's
amazing about that is not just the
quantity of soccer balls but they're all
made in one town Wow as well and this
industry goes back to the 1890s and
when a British sergeant I'll stay a
local Pakistani saddle producer to
repair his soccer ball and he was
stationed in in Punjab and add the
saddle maker said I'll make you another
soccer ball if you want and the rest was
history um so yes they have a very large
soccer ball industry they sort of
dominate one particular segment which is
the hand stitch soccer balls china china
has now taken a lot of the machine
stitch market which is sort of cheaper
lower quality soccer balls in general so
in this project it sort of a quite
different tack rather looking at these
small rug producers who are one two
three four person farms we're looking at
some very large firms the largest has
2,200 employees and so these are large
producers in the town of sialkot in
punjab and the sort of question here was
we were trying to understand both the
process of technology adoption as well
as how technology spread between firms
and the reason why this is an
interesting question is firstly if
you're interested in increasing
innovation or productivity than
technology is obviously a key part of
that but also a lot of industrial
policies that governments put in place I
predicated on the fact that there are
sort of spill overs between firms and so
if they have for example subsidized are
the technology for one firm it will then
spill over to other firms in the country
and that actually justifies subsidizing
it in the first place because it's
possible the firm itself wouldn't want
to pay for that given that many of the
benefits that are going to the other
firms rather than just themselves so so
in particular what we've been looking
for is we were thinking as with the
Egypt project we needed a some place to
try and investigate this phenomenon and
what we wanted to do is we wanted to see
if we introduced a new technology what
would happen would people adopt that
technology if they adopted it how would
it spread within sort of the networks of
firms in a cluster so it came to our
attention that there was this large
cluster of soccer balls manufacturers in
CL cod and we sort of investigated
further and we thought this
relationships or tile our cluster for us
to contemplate and innovation and so the
sort of history behind the innovation is
is somewhat interesting we initially
hired a consultant who had previously
worked in the soccer ball industry and
asked him if he could come up with some
sort of innovation that could i'd say
reduce costs and then we could think
about handing this to a subset of the
firms in a random manner well that's
pretty amazing and he felled
unfortunately he didn't take the money
we offered him he went down and he tried
but he'd previously innovated in the
cutting technology they use I had to cut
the Pentagon's and hexagons that you
form together to make a bull and so that
said our minds thinking and one of my
co-authors Eric ver Hugin was doing a
little bit of industrial espionage on
YouTube looking at a sort of promotional
video for the production of the two
thousand and I guess it was the 2006
world cup ball or I would have no idea
it's okay though what did he find and in
the video for how they produce that ball
and they showed them cutting a sheet of
pentagons using a very different pattern
of cuts to the one that he'd seen when
he had recently visited sialkot and he
thought maybe we can do better than
they're currently doing and it turns out
that the way they were cutting
Pentagon's in CL cod was the same way
that they were cutting hexagons which is
essentially you take a pentagon shape
and you put it next to another pentagon
shape
and then you on it's a flush on its side
and then you stamp down stamp down stamp
down and if you do that with a hexagon
then you fill a plane you tessellate a
plane because you can you can perfectly
fit hexagons into each other in order to
fill a rectangle okay now you can't do
that with Pentagon's but they were using
the sort of same design that they add
for the hexagons so it turns out there's
a better design for Pentagon's where you
sort of rotate the two dice slightly so
you can get more Pentagon's onto a plane
so you're not wasting any material right
and the reason why this is important is
these material costs which is
essentially an artificial leather that
they make which is what they're cutting
the panels out of is approximately fifty
percent of the total costs so any
reduction in wastage actually hits their
bottom line so Eric and his wife who's
an architect at so tried to see what
take what they saw on the video and
implemented into a design and we then
sort of brought this technology to see
our court and tried it out we got some
guys made and indeed we were able to
obtain between say six and ten percent
more Pentagon's per sheet when you use
this altered I go check that additional
die and so that corresponds to
approximately one a one-half percent
cost reduction so that doesn't sound
like an enormous amount but the sort of
median profits of these firms are about
eight percent and so that's a
significant ten fishing percenter that
profits and so this is a desirable
innovation so we basically went and
provided this technology both the dies
and the design and it connects patient
how to use it to a random subset of
funds that happened and so the idea was
actually twofold was first we wanted to
see if they took up the technology and
condition on taking up the technology
wanted to see how this technology spread
across firms within the town so we
collected very very detailed information
on on networks between owners between
workers
where they purchaser supplies from if
they had earth Nick ties etc and the
idea was to try and map these
information flows so what has happened
up to this point is that there has been
some adoption of the died but so far
less adoption than we initially
anticipated given our cost calculations
which suggested that this was really a
beneficial technology and why do you
think that is so one hypothesis is that
the technology is actually not that
effective so we don't think that's true
and the reason is approximately 11 I
think 10 or 11 firms have have adopted
the technology and one farm in
particular who's one of the largest
firms in town have actually purchased 37
of these dies sequentially so if the
technology wasn't any good maybe you'd
buy one of them and then decide oh this
doesn't work but they've basically moved
most of their production over to this
new cutting method and this is its of
leading from so it's clear that when
properly adopted this technology seems
to be profitable so this was a bit of a
puzzle so we sort of inquired further
and sort of one interesting dimension is
this firm which I just mentioned they
were a bit different to almost every
other firm in the town in that in
general these cutters who were actually
asked to use the dye and stamp out these
shapes are paid using our piece rate so
they're paid per ball that they cut but
in this firm they were paid a fixed wage
so you're paid for the hours you turn up
to work and we heard and we did a small
sort of qualitative survey that the main
reason firms weren't adopting was
because there was a lot of resistance
from their cutters as well as their
printers and so we sort of thought about
this some more and then we realized that
what we hypothesize is going on is if
you're being paid piece rate IE bubble
and your boss says here's a new
technology please start using this
technology it's going to save the firm
money it's not going to save the cutter
any money
since he doesn't care how much wastage
there is he's just paper ball I but what
it is going to do is it's going to slow
him down he has to sort of change the
way he moves his hands in order to move
these dyes across he has to learn he has
to be more careful initially and because
it's sort of harder to get this shape
that you've never done before in this
new shape on this new using this new die
and so essentially he's going to sort of
be slowed down as he has to learn how to
adapt the new technology how to use it
so there's a learning curve as a
learning curve and well he learns he
gets paid less and when he gets up to
speed he doesn't get any more and so it
sort of struck us that of course these
guys would be resisting and potentially
also misinforming their owners the
owners of the phones about exactly how
effective this technology was since they
didn't have any desire to to adapt it to
take this sort of shoot a hit as they
learned how to use so we were sort of
intrigued by this idea so actually right
now in the field we have a sort of a
complementary experiment where we've
taken the firm's who we previously
provide the technology with and a random
subset of them we've actually turned up
and we've attempted to offer what we
think is a more effective wage contract
to their workers in effect we're paying
them a sort of fixed wage for one month
so they come up to speed with the
learning curve and I don't had to do it
and so they're not taking this sort of
hit initially and what we're hoping to
find and pre very very preliminary
results are encouraging is that this
will spur significant adoption and so
what's sort of quite interesting about
this is and somewhat unexpected is it
implies that there are sort of these
organizational barriers to technology
adoption and and those are when the
incentives of the owners and the workers
who actually have to use the technology
and misaligned and
and this can be because it sort of the
structure of wage contracts are within
the fun and so in terms of the
implications obviously this is extremely
a preliminary begorrah should should
government's want to encourage a
technology adoption you may also need to
encourage the use of incentive
mechanisms within organisations which
ensure that these technologies will be
successfully adopted which often goes
beyond simply rewarding the CEO with
some sort of subsidy that may also
involve having some mechanism such that
the work is down the line and order sort
of adversely affected are doing the
adoption period very good I am curious
rug soccer balls how do you go about
choosing the industry so to speak well
so in the in the rugs case we we weren't
particularly set on rugs visa the other
products that were made for export the
way we ended up choosing rugs were as I
mentioned we chose Egypt because the
sort of partner organization we were
working with was going into Egypt it
seemed like an ideal setting it was sort
of a clean slate for them and we
actually didn't initially choose rugs
the first industry we chose was bed
sheets so we spoke to farms and at the
same time as we were sort of setting
things up on the ground the NGO was
attempting to drum up orders and
interest in these Egyptian made bed
sheets on Weston in western markets at
trade fairs etc and there simply wasn't
interest the Indians were charging
approximately half the price that the
Egyptian producers could sell at and
people actually preferred the Indian
product and so we ended up with rugs as
a sort of second try and actually if you
look at the literature the second try
was actually not bad since this
organization has approximately thirty
percent success rate approximately one
out of every three
the industry they try and go into their
they're able to actually generate sort
of sustained orders and sort of matches
up with generally most exporter's don't
succeed they try and export and then
they they pull back and any a few firms
which become very big successful
exported actually do succeed so so rugs
was our second shot the nice thing about
rugs is is these are sort of hand a flat
weave and hand-woven rugs is there is a
sort of sentiment in western markets
that the middle east is a top producer
of these rugs which is perhaps not the
view of bedspreads where the indian seem
to be far more successful so so I think
sort of a combination of this is a sort
of compared to advantage industry in the
Middle East and they were able to
produce high-quality products that are
reasonably a cheap price there were a
variety of other industries which didn't
suit our our requirements are quite as
well in terms of the industry structure
were there lots of small firms we could
work with very interesting which we also
dispatch and what about the soccer ball
so the soccer balls vs baseball's for
instance you know haha they don't make a
bit less messy out god so what we were
really looking for was a cluster where
there are many firms located close to
each other that's why we think these
sort of technology spill overs are going
to be strongest and easiest to
understand as well and so I guess I I
just a question just popped up in my
head with the technology spillover if
I'm if I'm manufacturing soccer balls
wouldn't I want all the business I mean
wouldn't I not want the technology to
spill over to other people oh absolutely
so the funds and these are large firms
have a strong incentive to to protect
the technology okay however we haven't
spoken to the fans now and seeing the
prices that are occurred even with the
small number of spill overs that we've
observed in in in the town there's
plenty of people who aren't so careful
such as some of the workers at the firm
or the suppliers of the dyes for example
and even though you're active you may
well tell your brother-in-law right who
who also has a firm so in a lot of these
families you know maybe there's a
grandfather who had or great-grandfather
who started the firm and then over the
generations there are now multiple firms
run by various member family and they
intermarry as well across farms and so
there are approximately a hundred and
forty firms making soccer balls in
sialkot right now so it's a large
industry and so there's a lot of these
different channels and in sort of the
and the next project we're working on is
is to try and to start looking into that
data and trying to understand the roots
through which the technology spreads
these technologies do spread right and
that will also help plus makers say they
want to know if they do want to
subsidize some innovation which firms
are the ones which provide biggest bang
for your buck so to speak as well as how
larger these spill overs what kind of
industrial policies will they justify
okay well we'll look forward to seeing
that from you so thank you very much for
being here with us today and sharing
some of your work thank you very much
for having me for more information about
professor atkin and his work please
visit our website at yale edu slash
macmillan report be sure to join us
again for another episode of the
macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale
you